اتحد وزراء دفاع اوروبا ضد روسيا لكن
الخلافات برزت عندما حان وقت حسمك قرار
ارسال دبابات ثقيله من عدمه وزير الدفاع
الالماني اوضح بعد لقاء جمع كافه الوزراء
انه لم يتخذ اي قرار فيما يتعلق بارسال
الدبابات الى كاذب تخشى برلين من ان تعتبر
موسكو ذلك تجاوزا للخط الاحمر
الانطباع بان هناك تحالف موحد وانا
المانيا تقف حاجزا امامه انطباع خاطئ هناك
العديد من الخلفاء الذين يقولون انهم
يشاركون الراي الذي اشارته هناك اسباب
وجها لارسال الدبابات واخرى غير منطقيه
من بين الحلفاء الذين يتحدث عنهم الوزير
الالماني الولايات المتحده التي تتردد الى
الساعه في ارسال الدبابات الى اوكرانيا
بسبب متطلبات التدريب والصيانه لكن وزير
الدفاع الامريكيه حارسه على ان يضع في
الواجهه المساعدات العسكريه الامريكيه
لكيف خلال الاسابيع المقبله في اشاره منه
الى المليارين ونصف المليار دولار التي
وعدت بها واشنطن
عدد من الدول
الاوكرانيه وسمائها نقوم بكل ما في وسعنا
للرد على مطالب اوكرانيا
المملكه المتحده اعلنت عن تقديمها دبابات
من نوع شلنجر
وافقا لخبراء عسكريين يمكن ان تكون
للدبابات الثقيله الحديثه ذات التصميم
الغربي ميزه حاسمه لكيف على جبهه الشرقيه
في الاسابيع المقبله رسميا لا يوجد ما
يدعو للقلق بشان الكريم لان الذي يؤكد ان
عمليات التسليم هذه لن تغير اي شيء على
الارض